[Music]
when i was a kid i
lost a lot of my baby teeth in like
third grade
and that's when i think i started
watching like criminal minds and like
law order svu
so i would keep all my baby teeth in a
leg in our coffee table in our living
room
because for some reason i wanted to
convince people that like if i died
young that my parents killed me even
though that's not what happened just my
baby teeth so
that's my secret
[Music]
um
i'm like
i'm 13 and i feel like i always have to
be like super grown up about things
um and this is one of the first times in
a very long time that i've been like
childish and
that means a lot to me um like i went to
the zoo today and i got my face painted
and everything and i just i feel a lot
better being more myself
[Music]
when i was 16 i was molested by a
classmate
and it
kind of drove me
insane um and i ended up staying in a
psych ward and then
had to
withdraw
from high school
for the time being um anyway i went
through a whole
court case process
and unfortunately because i had close
people
like close relationships with people who
also knew
my assailant they
testified against me and thus all
charges were dropped
well
maybe a year ago or a little less than
that i sent an email
[Music]
to this individual who is on a mormon
mission like basically not forgiving him
for what he did
but saying like
sorry
for
putting his family
through the financial hardship of a
court case
um but i just i really regret sending
that now because after i did um i found
out
um
another girl that i'm friends with was
also assaulted by this same
individual
and it makes me sick
and i
as much as i don't want it to happen to
other girls
i just hope that
justice is served
[Music]
i'm still best friends with my assaulter
[Music]
my secret is that i prefer to be
depressed rather than being okay just
because i feel more i guess
comforted in my own depression and it's
kind of like a security blanket for me
[Music]
i wanna explore my gender identity and i
have internalized homophobia and
transphobia that
[Music]
makes it hard for me to feel
like
i am
deserving
of of doing that for myself
but i know i can do it i know you can
too
[Music]
when i was
an adolescent
i was on some medication for anger
problems and mood swings and stuff and
it was called risperdal and by the end
of this you might not think it was that
intriguing of a secret but
taking that medication started to
fumble
my hormones or something like that
and basically if i can just be as crude
as possible i started to grow tits
at an early age i told my friend about
this
and he sort of made fun of me and he's
one of my best friends and i guess he
it
i don't know it was just sort of like
it was something really
sensitive that i brought to light and
just bringing it up to someone who i
trusted and just kind of being
shut down in a way or at least laughed
at just made me a little bit
um
insecure so
that's it
even though my job is to help people
and i try to be the best person that i
can
i still have moments where i think mean
things about people
and i feel conflicted about it
[Music]
my secret is that i think i have a fear
of
there might be something mentally
not right but i think i'm too scared to
actually get it
looked at and i think that's something
that just like bothers me
[Music]
i haven't told my parents that i was
diagnosed with depression because i
don't want to worry them
[Music]
i feel like therapy will never help me
[Music]
so
when i was younger
for some reason i was like
attracted to sonic the hedgehog
like i really wanted to like have a
freaking plushie of him
or something so i could like hug it or
something i
don't know
why
and i don't know how i didn't realize
from earlier on that i wasn't straight
i've slept with both the husband and the
wife from a marriage and neither of them
know
[Music]
all right my secret is that my first
crush was um
anne frank
so i'm a tattoo person and one that i
keep hidden from other people is that i
have a piece of cake
tattooed right in the middle of my butt
because
you can't tell me that i don't got cake
[Music]
i i feel like i wear a mask and i
haven't really revealed my true self yet
oh god
i'm completely in love with the girl who
was next to me when you asked this
question i have not told her she in
theory has no idea that's why i said
that i would give her privacy for her
for her secret and then when she said i
had to go first i was like okay but
we're going around the corner where the
shade is because i needed her to not
know that
[Music]
i am okay with the fact that my
ex-boyfriend cheated on me because it
gave me a reason to sleep with women
[Music]
i'm a health care provider and i used to
be addicted to drugs and i have spent
about forty thousand dollars in my life
on cocaine
i finally was able to ask for help from
friends and family and went to rehab and
i am now been sober for
a little over two years
uh i hated being my parents daughter for
a very long time
but spending this weekend down here with
them
i realized how much they've grown as
people
especially being gay
they were very homophobic in their past
but they've accepted me and loved me
with open arms and
today now i'm very grateful for them
[Music]
so
last summer my partner and i
we discussed that you know we both
wanted to know our heritage
he always knew his but i really didn't
know mine
so i decided to get a 23andme kit and
when i got the results it said i had a
half sister so i called my mom and i
asked her you know i didn't have the
best relationship with my dad growing up
um but
i said oh maybe he had another kid maybe
i can connect with this person and she
abruptly hung up the phone and she
called me back and she told me that it
was actually not my dad
and that
the sister that i had was
from my biological dad who she did not
know she claims to not know was my
father so
i found out just about
you know back last summer that my who i
thought was my dad who put me through a
lot of trauma actually
is not my dad
[Music]
i found out that my dad wasn't my dad
from a 23andme
and i lost interest in hanging out with
that side of my family
my secret is
i'm afraid of making mistakes
i think
i can be really hard on myself sometimes
and
occasionally sometimes i find it
relieving to to make a mistake um
because
it just makes me feel more human and
um i feel
like i can i can see that it's not the
end of the world when i do make mistakes
so
even though it's scary
there is some degree of like
relief
that i find in making mistakes
so i am graduating medical school this
year and i was able to match into a
residency program
for pediatrics and so i'll be taking
care of little children and
i'm just worried that
i won't be good enough
and
i will cause harm more harm than good
and it's it's such a it's
frightening to have those lives beyond
me and my decisions making such a huge
impact on their
on on their lives and their families
lives and so i think you can't really
do much in life if you let fear dictate
what you do i guess it's good to to feel
to feel afraid but
just make sure it doesn't paralyze you
thank you for letting me share with you
[Music]
hey everyone try here i wanted to say
thank you for watching this episode i am
still selling these sweaters on my
website if you're interested i'll link
in my description i love you guys and
i'll see you next week
[Music]